should outrage every single person i
don't care if you're a democrat i don't
care if you're a republican
the only thing that joe biden is doing
on the border
is not trying to stop illegal
immigration he's trying to accelerate it
they're building more facilities
for the sole purpose of expediting the
release of illegal migrants into the
interior
he is the first president in our
lifetimes
indeed in the history of the country who
has ever attempted
such a program
and that was former senior white house
adviser stephen miller on this program
earlier this month revealing the biden
administration's plan
to push people through the facilities
quickly
alleviate overcrowding at the border and
house them
in new facilities now he wants to pay
for it
they're doing it last month border
patrol reported over 178
000 apprehensions that's a 20-year high
yet as of last week only 455 miners were
in their custody
so where are all of these people going
joining me right now is former dhs
acting secretary chad wolf he's
currently a visiting fellow at the
heritage foundation
secretary it's great to see you this
morning thanks very much for being here
well it looks like we are
pushing the migrants into the interior
of our country
as much as possible the administration
has built a lot more housing
to house these people but they're also
trying to help them
connect with so-called sponsors or
family that they say
they have in cities across the country
your reaction to where we are
halfway through the year now
well thanks for having me on maria i
think what we uh currently are and what
we see going on at the borders we are
continue to be in the middle of a
historic crisis
on our southwest border you talked about
dhs and the progress they've made
the department and the administration
are trying to take a victory lap at the
moment
talking about how they're moving
migrants mainly minors
from one government facility to another
government facility and saying we've
solved the price
the problem and the crisis and that's
anything uh they have done
anything but that um solving the crisis
is actually trying to stop the illegal
behavior they're not interested in doing
that
they've torn down a number of programs
that we put in place back in 2019 and
2020 and they have not replaced it with
any
uh programs and policies to address the
illegal behavior again
they're just simply facilitating more
and more of these migrants coming across
the border
okay what is what is needed at this
point i mean
look this is a dangerous trek this is
not just
an economic issue for this country but
this is a human humanitarian crisis
where young girls are getting sexually
assaulted
as they make this track
well absolutely what's needed is to make
sure that you're not only
putting the right policies in place but
you're putting the right messaging in
place
and so they need to bring back either
the migrant protection protocols our
asylum cooperative agreements they need
to
show the migrants and the cartels and
the smugglers that it's not okay
to continue to smuggle miners and
families across that border
but more importantly it's to make sure
that there's a consequence to that
behavior so as long as those populations
stay in the u.s once they come across
that border these numbers and this flow
is going to continue
it's not until these folks are removed
promptly back to their home countries
back to mexico
and elsewhere that you're going to see
some of this start to decrease it's what
we did in 2019 and 2020
and guess what it worked the numbers
went down the crime went down the
apprehensions went down and we got the
border
under control so we know it works there
is a playbook
this administration simply uh chooses
not to
institute some of those policies
yeah we've been talking about the budget
this morning which president biden
unveiled on friday the department of
homeland security secretary mayorkas
told lawmakers that the administration
is seeking 52.2 billion dollars in
funding
for the coming fiscal year leaving the
agency's budget unchanged
so despite this massive surge
the budget is unchanged but now
president biden is asking
for more money to pay for all of this
housing
i mean it just gets me that there's
absolutely no effort whatsoever to stop
people from coming here illegal jumping
jumping the line in front of people who
are actually
trying to do it legally get their green
cards and instead he's asking for money
through congress he wants money to pay
for technology and these additional
housing
facilities that they just built
well it's unfathomable that dhs and all
the homeland security threats that the
department tries to assess
and to address on a daily basis is
there's not an increased funding for the
department
so it's not only the southwest border
and the migrant and the humanitarian the
security crisis that we're dealing with
but it's also cyber security and it's a
variety of these other threats
threats from china that we're dealing
with here in the homeland that the
department needs to continue to push
forward at the end of the day we need to
make sure that americans are safe and
secure
and it's going to take resources to do
that and so the fact that the
administration is not focusing on that
and is focusing on building these
facilities and giving more money to hhs
to build more of these facilities again
shows me that they're not serious about
trying to stop
the problem instead of managing the
crisis they need to solve the crisis
and again they're not they're not
currently doing that we heard the
secretary just yesterday talk about
possibly reprogramming money within the
department to address
the humanitarian and security crisis on
the southwest border so clearly
there's a resource need there clearly
they're spending more money than they
have
at the moment and so as you look towards
the next fiscal year
that's going to continue as these
numbers in the second half of the year
these numbers continue to increase
yeah and and also we're all wondering
where all of these people are going
we spoke with senator marcia blackburn
recently she joined me on fox business
on my morning
program there to talk to us about the
fact that
we have seen or she has seen planes
touching down in chattanooga
filled with migrants they sent them to
tennessee
ken paxton in texas is also questioning
whether or not
they're actually sending migrants to red
states
uh because at the end of the day the
cost will fall to the state
here's marcia blackburn joining me
recently on this very issue watch this
what we know is that the biden
administration is absolutely living in
fantasyland
if they're telling people that that
border is secure
they have apprehended 500 000
illegal entrants since joe biden took
office
and what they've begun to do is to move
them
out and about around the country so that
they are
offloading the cost for housing child
services health care education to the
states and the counties
and what we have found out is
that they had these planes coming into
chattanooga
putting these children on buses
and then taking them to communities
around the area
that that's actually extraordinary
secretary what do you what do you make
of that and
and by the way uh andy biggs the arizona
congressman
is calling on alejandro uh mayorkas to
be removed
in the face of all of this uh andy biggs
writes a new op-ed for foxnews.com and
in it he writes the rationale and
results of biden's inhumane border
crisis
can be set at the feet of biden's
hand-picked homeland security secretary
mayorka's pr prevarications and utter
failure
to protect americans from the invasion
across our southern border
demonstrate that he is unfit to serve if
majorcase refuses to step down congress
should initiate impeachment proceedings
your reaction
well a couple of comments senator marcia
blackburn is
exactly right what they're doing at the
border right now is they are breaking
the system
there are too many miners in custody for
the amount of facilities that they have
so what do they have to do they then
have to move those individuals
to other parts of the country and so
what we say now is that every city every
state
in the country is now a border state and
a border community because they are
pushing
these populations all across the country
because they have broken the system the
system has
never been designed or accounted for to
hold these number of individuals into
process these numbers of individuals
these are historic highs 21-year high
in the amount of folks that are coming
across that border and into facilities
so
she's exactly right they are moving
these miners these family units and
others
to all sorts of communities across uh
across the country
uh we're so she's a 100 percent correct
on that
uh look i have significant concerns with
the dhs secretary and the types of
policies that he is pursuing i think
they're making the country less safe
they're making our men and women of
border patrol the law enforcement
officers less safe
and at the end of the day they're doing
a disservice to the migrants when they
encourage these migrants to make this
dangerous trek up and then at the same
time he continues to say the border is
closed and the border is secure
and that is a lie that's the light of
the american people he's misleading the
american people
on purpose because he's done it he's
done it multiple
multiple times and so you have to
account for that and you have to wonder
why he is doing that
and i think he needs to be held
accountable for that but at the end of
the day this is about protecting the
homeland and making sure that we have
the right policies in place
great to see you chad wolfe thanks very
much for laying it all out we of course
will continue to spotlight it
former secretary of homeland security
chad wolfe thank you sir